[Music]
so I got a message the other day on
Instagram and a person said Pat I've
been following the content for a couple
years but men no matter how much I get
after it it just doesn't happen for me
I'm not making my money and I said
listen I want you to understand maybe
you're a terrible entrepreneur and this
person says oh my gosh I cannot even
believe you were saying something like
this because what do you mean I'm a
terrible entrepreneur would you let me
know wanting to do this episode today
and this may be a pep talk to you and
I'm specifically talking to people that
have been around for less than five
years as an entrepreneur some of you
that I've been on for a long time but
your business isn't popping we're gonna
really figure out if you're an
entrepreneur or not and by the way any
questions or thoughts comment below and
if you haven't subscribe to the channel
click on the subscribe button let me
give you the first one here that's gonna
stink maybe you're a terrible
entrepreneur because you are full of
[ __ ] is what you are and let me explain
to what I mean by you're full of [ __ ]
everything that comes out of your mind
you're trying to convince everybody how
committed you are but you are not
committed you're full of it you're
trying to fool everybody into believe in
you and no one believes you because even
you don't believe your stuff when you
say stuff to other people of course
you're not gonna make in the world of
business maybe you want to just go back
and get a job let me give you the second
one you really think you're Steve Jobs
or Elon Musk you think Steve Jobs any
llamas came together and put their
chromosomes together and boom they
created you and you're this perfect kid
who's got all the greatest ideas and
thoughts and no one's as smart as it is
as you are you're not Steve Jobs
you're not a llamas do you know when
you'll be considered Steve Jobs or Elon
Musk probably when you die or maybe 10
20 years from that's gonna take a very
long time when other people say that
about you then it becomes a reality let
me give you the third one here do you
think you know everything you think you
know everything just because you read
several books if you read blue ocean
strategy you let read written Lean
Startup you read a book over here on the
principles by Ray Dalio and you read
Michael Porter comparison you read some
of these books and oh my gosh I have a
degree from this and you don't
understand listen believe me you don't
know everything when you have there's
certain things in life that don't come
with a manual parenting is one of them
being an entrepreneur is another one
there's a lot of curveballs that comes
into place so when you go with the
attitude of thinking you know it all and
all of a sudden you realize you don't
boom you're wiped out of the business
here let me give you a fourth one you
are terrible with money what do I mean
by you're terrible with money you don't
even know how to handle your own money
you your expenses are not covered you
you're late on your cell phone bill
you're late on your car bill you're late
on everything rent you're later mondo
you're everything you're late on
everything you're doing and you're
trying to be a business so do you
realize how much your brain is consumed
with everything being made under panic
management decisions because you're a
freak has your money issues are not
writing you try to go build a business
for yourself though still doing good
together
this isn't an idea but let me go put
everything I have on my credit cards and
constable my business believe me I have
that from experience and it didn't work
those things don't work I was in a real
entrepreneur when I was calling myself
an entrepreneur and maybe you are not
either maybe you need an upgrade let me
give you the fifth one here you talk
down to people everybody that works for
you think like they owe you everything
you you're bossing in Marana you're
getting this whole boss hashtag idea and
you're putting instagram bosses if
you're a boss you're not a boss bosses
are not entrepreneurs bosses are
managers you don't go out there and
become an entrepreneur call yourself a
boss you're not a boss and entrepreneur
everybody else is your boss everybody
tells you what to do I don't come to
work and tell people what to do they
tell me what to do they give me
different things that we need to be
doing a nice process issues with them
and we figure out which to do something
together do you think a business is
gonna be built without the people that
are really building a business yes
you're the founder yes you could be the
entrepreneur but you think you're
bossing everybody everybody talking down
at them and tell them all this other
stuff like they're gonna want to work
for you long term it doesn't work that
way maybe you're not ready to be an
entrepreneur you need an upgrade let me
give you the next one you're point
number six you think your idea is unique
like you really think your ideas the
greatest thing since sliced bread
at this point here's one thing you got
to realize most ideas have already been
thought of by somebody else hey this is
not the most ridiculous you didn't have
this aha moment and you had all this
stuff and all of us in your idea came
out and you know your best friend sat
down and said oh my gosh ooh the most
ridiculous guy that comes up with insane
ideas relax it's a good idea it's not a
crazy idea the implementation is half
the battle of coming up with the idea
but your idea isn't as crazy as you
think it is implementation and what you
do afterwards on your execution could
pass
validate that your idea is a decent idea
as long as there's a leader behind it to
drive this great idea of yours that you
came up with let me give you the next
point here you panic very easily the
slightest thing happens you panic some
happen with President Trump and Kanye
West said make America great again
oh my gosh it's the end of the world all
of a sudden Kim Kardashian comes out
with it you know maybe this picture she
posts on Twitter oh my goodness did you
see Kim car did you see what happened
over here did you see what the market
said did you see what dispersed
everything to use panic somebody quit oh
my gosh this person is all about on
everything this panic panic panic panic
panic panic panic you know what it is to
work around somebody that's panic all
the time
it drives that person insane it is very
insane to be around somebody that
constantly panics the purpose of being
an entrepreneur is you know how to hold
it together emotionally stable it's okay
we'll figure it out everything's gonna
be okay
and then you gather thoughts and you
figure out a way to have the solution to
move forward next point here for you
number eight you are constantly seeking
this thing called work/life balance that
doesn't exist and you want to call
yourself an entrepreneur it's like
saying hey I really want to make it into
the MBA but dude I want to play video
games and kick in and sleep and all day
but I still want to get into the NBA it
doesn't work that way there is no such
thing as work-life balance when you're
trying to do something that a very small
percentage of people in the world do
there's only 500 people in the NBA it's
not like a million people in the NBA
there's only a few hundred billionaires
you know let's say 2000 billionaires
it's not like it's a million
billionaires yes there's millions of
millionaires but that millions of
millionaires is one out of 300 which
means you've really got to get out there
and work you you can be seeking
work/life balance too early it doesn't
work out that way this whole thing about
wanting to have the lifestyle and the
cars and the Ferraris and the Rolex and
the jewelry and the looks too early that
is not the mindset of an entrepreneur
that comes later on delayed
gratification number 9 you want quick
money doesn't work that way there is no
such thing as quick money in business
money takes a while especially if it's a
legitimate business now you're building
I've seen a lot of people make a lot of
quick money and I've seen a lot of
people have a quick bankruptcy as well
because they
quick money those two don't go together
typically solid businesses takes a lot
takes a while to build because you got
to go through a lot of issues challenges
and as you're going through that the
real development of it is not the
business it's you the leader is becoming
a better leader and the business keeps
getting better and better and better as
you become a stronger leader the tenth
one for you you hate to be wrong and let
me break it down how it is to be an
entrepreneur and entrepreneur doesn't
wake up and saying I have to be right
today because I have a degree and I
better be right today it doesn't work
that way
you're wrong most of the time however
when you're right at one time and you
really are right at one time and you do
it right for a few years at one time
that's when all of a sudden you get this
big victory of a million ten million one
hundred million maybe a billion dollars
or some people that are in a marketplace
that's got a lot of opportunity expense
so now that you heard tenable have I
hurt your feelings do you hate me right
now are you upset are you gonna call
your mom and say this man named Patrick
may live it on YouTube hurt my feelings
I don't like this man I still like him I
don't like him anymore listen sometimes
someone like me because your parents may
not do it because to your parents you're
the most incredible thing since sliced
bread
sometimes your spouse won't do it
although your wife may send you this
video if you get this video from your
boyfriend or girlfriend they're trying
to tell you something just so you know
this it's not like oh babe I think
you're gonna like this video you're
trying to tell you babe you got to get
your act together because one of these
10 things is you but hopefully you're
watching this you're not gonna have an
ego so big that no one can tell you that
you have issues that you need to fix
because if you are in that area you'll
be like the 2223 or a version of me
Patrick made David who lost everything
he had who had 49 thousand dollars of
debt and he thought he knew everything
and nothing worked this way and I had to
adjust so I can save you a lot of years
of stress of lost money and lost time if
you are willing to take this message and
internalize it and say shoot maybe I do
need to make some adjustments hopefully
you can do that having said that Mario's
gonna have a PDF for you right down
below they can download again questions
comments even some of you that are hurt
put your comments below maybe I'm gonna
come with a thank you're a happy face
for your who knows maybe one of these
flexing arm emoji that's out there to
make you feel good about yourself and
don't expect that I'm just kidding with
you're not gonna get that for me I want
you to toughen up because the world of
business is tough and last but not least
if you still after this video still are
willing to subscribe to this channel I
love you so much thanks for watching
everybody take care bye bye